how you doing why you look so cool
thanks yeah look at the chain look at
the jacket look at the fit thank you I'm
working hard and hardly working you
always working that's why you you so my
first question is for you we're going to
play a little game called this and that
okay so I'm going to give you two
options and you just tell me which one
you prefer okay flats or drumsticks
Flats okay classic tape and then grits
or sugar
grps grits with cheese grit with do you
put butter in it too got to have it all
the butter right up under the chees you
know what I'm talking about my last
question for you is what advice do you
have for The Underdogs keep on pushing
don't
stop it ain't where you start it's where
you end and if you keep on pushing
you'll go from Underdog to wonderdog you
put on the song you don't play no games
you just work 24/7 huh constant working
bab well thank you so much we appreciate
it